oui vanessa dont leur cerveau le temps
passant soit plus lentement
lesquels
si on la joue bien
on tiendra toute la ville
800 millions de personnes vivent dans
les ruines de l'ancien monde
il n'ya qu'un recours pour faire régner
l'ordre dans ce chaos
les hommes et les femmes du palais de
justice
pitch trees et l'unique laboratoire qui
fournit mega city one ans le mot les
juges se font plutôt rares peachtree
maintenant il y en a elles contrôlent
tout du niveau 1 à 2 cents
que si ma main tous se sont infiltrés
dans ce blog c'est pas bon
je les veux morts
est prête
oui tu en as l'air
du jugement
mama n'est pas la loi je suis la loi
fin de la négociation l'assistance et la
mort